hi I'm bill passings a representative
from your area I'm here to make all your
legislative dreams come true
are you a constituent looking for a do
you ever stay up all night wishing
someone would just listen to your voice
call us first I'm good
there you go all-american fun
[Music]
and tell us about any issue that you
deeply deeply care about marriage
equality renewable energy immigration
Freedom of Information reproductive
rights Porter will have here and so much
more
[Music]
and guess what you don't have to be over
18 to call it's fun for the whole family
no matter where you live where you come
from or what you believe in
we're here to listen there's nothing
sexier than active resistance use your
voice we are the people we have the
power we can make a difference so call
us now seriously it's not that hard hi
my name is Kevin I'm not a senator but I
am a member of the great big disco dance
party known as America what you just saw
was obviously a parody but the number
presented was absolutely real
call this number below and you'll be
connected to a switchboard where you can
contact your local member of Congress
these people depend on you and your vote
for their job so they want to hear from
you so if you're watching the news or
just scrolling through Facebook and
seeing angry memes and just feel angry
or hopeless just remember there's
something that you can do about it and
it's actually really easy just punch in
these ten beautiful digits and you'll be
connected to your specific Congress
person tell them your hopes your
opinions and your worries ask them how
they're gonna vote in particular bills
remember they work for you and trust me
they're gonna write this all down it's
their job if you want more information
about contacting your representative
take a look in the video description and
call your representative today I'm going
to call mine right now it's real easy
busy but we're gonna keep trying